[Applaudissements]
il y à un mois et demi noorda le landais
été condamné à la perpétuité pour le
meurtre de la jeune miley ce et jurés
ont suivi les réquisitions de l'avocat
général condamnation à la perpétuité
22 ans ferme
compressible aph depuis il est incarcéré
à la prison de saint-quentin-fallavier
en isère pour purger sa peine le centre
pénitentiaire n'a monde hors du monde
jeudi dernier il a été surpris par les
surveillants plein ébat sexuel au
parloir de la prison avec une femme qui
lui rendait visite pour la première fois
une femme avec qui nordahl aurait
entretenu une correspondance avant
qu'elle fasse les démarches pour obtenir
un droit de visite reconduit à sa
cellule normale de landais risquerait
jusqu'à 14 jours le quartier
disciplinaire et de perdre le peu de
liberté qui lui restait la femme quant à
elle est désormais interdite de visite
alors dordogne landes est surpris en
train d'avoir un rapport sexuel au
parloir de sa prison poty lui interdire
les visites
faut-il interdire les visites c'est
alors non gilles verdez gilles verdez
non non gilbert gress ans maintenant et
non gilbert dénombrions de genton géré a
dit j'ai commencé par tout ce qu'ils
vont me nervis vas-y alors on est dans
un état de droit et dans un état de
droit c'est évidemment très fort est
incroyable que des terroristes des
pédocriminels des serial killers et
droit des avocats pour les défendre ok
mais après moi aujourd'hui à titre
personnel de mères de famille m'a bien
sûr est insupportable mais insu sociale
des gages aux même pas imaginer les
parents superman mais ça m'est
insupportable d'entendre que normal le
landais peu à voir de près ou de loin
une vie qui ressemble à une certaine
normalité je ne veux pas qu'ils prennent
du plaisir je ne veux pas qu'il fasse
comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure ce
qui nous amène aussi grave voilà c'est
inaudible je ne peux pas longtemps je
sais qu'il a le droit je sais que c'est
possible mais je vois là je veux je veux
que la schl à la loi change je veux
voilà c'est pas possible c'est inaudible
et j'ose même pas imaginer la douleur
des parents aujourd'hui voilà gilles
verdez pourquoi nous il a été condamné à
la perpétuité pour le meurtre de maëlys
avec une peine de sûreté de 22 ans la
justice a tranché et géraldine dit il
n'a pas le droit puis final si on ne lui
a pas interdit de vielles je sais il
peut recevoir des visites sur ce que
vous pouvez nous raconter de belles
histoires voilà c'est passé alors il
faut savoir que nordahl le landais ça va
surprendre beaucoup de gens reçoit
énormément de courriers féminin il ya
beaucoup de femmes qui a envie
d'entretenir une relation était folle
nom des femmes
est ce que disent tous les genres sont
les raisons
c'est trop simple de rire ces femmes à
débat voilà
d'accord mais vous savez qu'à des mêmes
données des visites de prison
dealer de drogue si tu veux mais pas un
pédophile à vous écrire aussi parce que
tu as de l'empathie parce que tu as
envie d'en faire des dégâts dans le
remettent dans le droit chaque de femmes
qui ont envie passagers ne parle pas du
tout ça jean elle avait dû à l'arrivée
des ordis dollars
kelly excusez moi mais que ça vous gêne
ou non il ya une fascination du
serial-killer du meurtrier sur certaines
femmes notamment cette femme qui est une
parisienne qui a entretenu avec lui une
longue correspondance et finalement il
ya une enquête du préfet c'est ça qui
est le plus fou il ya une enquête du
préfet on a jugé qu'elle n'avait pas
d'interdiction pas de casier judiciaire
elle a pu y aller le flash a été
immédiat entre eux et ce qui choque
c'est que c'était un paroisse normal
c'est pas un parloir de vie familiale où
vous avez le droit de faire l'amour
c'est alors normal mais légal tout ça au
nom non l'annoncé des dates du tout les
gars là va plus revenir je te lui va
être condamné à quatorze jours de mitard
très vraisemblablement torture et
d'homicide et ses bas comme ça les
gardiens sont très vite intervenus donc
il essaiera loi même dans la pression
rien n'y a rien qui le raccompagner ce
qui choque énormément c'est que ça remet
sur le tapis les privilèges dont qui
jouirait en prison que jamais on en a
parlé ici il ya eu des histoires avec
des femmes il aurait des privilèges ça
ça me choque mais combien cas mais oui
mais qu'on lui interdise les visites non
ça ne peut pas devenir une bête sauvage
à l' isolement pendant 22 ans est
impossible impossible hugo nommé le
parloir est considérée comme un lieu
public de quoi fait on applique la loi
c'est très simple ces quatorze jours oui
là il est hors la loi donc c'est
vraiment aussi simple que ça je vois pas
pourquoi enfin des arguments je les
comprends pas trop jaloux proche la
science et interdire devise est
définitivement ou panne on ne peut pas
l'interdire d'affinités
ça la question
avec ce qu'il a fait déjà il a droit à
des visites je suis d'accord il respecte
on
continue là il ne respecte pas il fait
quelque chose mais d' insensé avec son
passé évidemment il est il a été violent
avec des gardiens qui l'ont raccompagné
en prison avait foi dans sa cellule
alors qu'il faisait quelque chose
d'interdît et on va lui donner ou là là
le pauvre 14 jours de mitard
c'est-à-dire 14 juin dans toute façon il
est des gens en prison il est en germe
isolement quelle punition moi je suis
vraiment très ce pour lui et la justice
est bien fait et on va continuer comme
ça et on continuera à faire des débats à
dire que c'est dégueulasse mais on
continuera non il faut arrêter
de changer il faut changer cette
habitude de dire on est tu chantes
alizés tu vois là il y en deux ans il ya
quatre ans
videmment ce qu'il a fait et ils m'ont
dit doit payer pour la wii mais moi ce
qui me gêne c'est que j'ai l'impression
que ceux qui veulent lui interdire les
visites veulent l'empêcher de vivre tout
pas faire l'amour déjà tout ça
il a pris la prison à perpétuité
d'accord il a quand même le droit je ne
parle pas de relation sexuelle mais de
subvenir à ses besoins primaires de
manger de respirer de dormir
mélangez pas tout il a eu un rapport
consenti avec une femme majeure je ne
pense pas qu'il doit être interdite de
visite pour sa silva c'est quoi c'est la
peine de mort on l'enfer dans un trou il
fait plus rien mais au don de tuer et
c'est inhumain voilà c'est tout steevy
boulay
regardes tu 17e ben alors de vie moyenne
pour moi deux de survivre point barre
l'acteur de survivre et on tolère sur
terre pour le tolère cet homme là a fait
des choses qui sont innommable qui
serait supportable il n'a pas pris la
douane avant aucun droit voilà c'est le
minimum vital le reste non non mais on
oublié un petit détail il a quand même
eu accès à des téléphones portables dont
alors on sait que dans les prisons les
gardiens font ce qu'ils peuvent c'est
difficile il ya des choses qui passent
et il a il en a profité pour prendre
contact avec une lycéenne avec tout ça
donc tout cela on ajoute et on va voilà
on va dire que c'est dégoûtant ce à des
coûts de six mois
la justice continue
[Applaudissements]
suffit pas apparemment il ya par gilles
tout le monde est révolté mais ça ne
suffira pas ça continuera la loi est
comme ça moi je vous avais parlé de ce
que je pensais de lui et moi guillot
midi sinon c'est la peine de mort et
c'est vraiment elle est contre la loi
aux sirènes de changer jour soûlard
alors annoncé bayonnais on y va demain
mon avis mon avis moi c'est que
appartement vous laisser en vie vous
l'avez laisse en vie lui et plein
d'autres qui s'attaque à des gamines
comme ça moi je vous ai dit que ces mecs
là ils ont rien à faire sur terre avec
donc moi à partir du moment où tu l'as
tu le laisses comme ça ben maintenant il
a droit d'avoir un permis de visite
comme les autres comme le temps comme
d'un autre remake devrait désigner
maintenance qui déconne c'est la nana
qui vient chercher juste sur les réseaux
sociaux qui vient lui parler qui danse
dans la salle étant associé à un rapport
qui ressent et c'est quoi cette barge
manger nos par hector d'abord pour
écrire un prisonnier s'est pas sur les
réseaux sociaux ou alors il faut alors
la correspondance de nouvelles
invitations à me balader les bisounours
bien sûr ils ont tous un platane mars s
est passé de parts et des femmes bien
sûr exception les réseaux
non mais ajoute j'ai autorisé de
téléphoner à quelqu'un d'abord en ayant
d'abord demandé l'autorisation à
l'administration payer les riches
valérie valérie dans aleris valérie
valérie je te le dis là tu dis des
bêtises
mais tout le monde a des téléphones
orange jeudi j'ai des potes
maintenant qu'ils vont aux familles si
des gens ont peur d'aller le voir c'est
des gens dans sa famille dit je vous
aime bien qui vient si sa mère à vallet
loire et c est là qu aller le voir si
maintenant il ya d'autres gens ils ont
envie d'aller voir un mec catch une
gamine de 7 ans qui a fait des actes
sexuels et qu'une gamine de 16 ans c'est
leur moral et leur moral pour moi ces
gens là c'est des bars pour mars et ils
sont comme lui c'est pareil la nana qui
a envoyé le téléphone pour me refaire
l'amour avec un mec qui a tué une gamine
de cette raison la prison avait fuité
comme lui tu vaux rien du tout cpb
à
horrible non mais donc vous êtes pour la
peine de mort oui mais moi je suis moi
je te dis quand on regarde je regarde je
redis encore fort ces mecs là qu'est ce
que je vais me prendre la tête à lui
donne à manger en prison qu'est ce que
je vais me prend
[Applaudissements]
hier et français que les problèmes on a
tous des problèmes on n'a pas à nourrir
mais comme ça il va ressortir un jour
les trous profonds n'est pas du on peut
pas je ne peux pas dire que quelqu'un
mérite à mort pour le dire mais qu'elle
allait bien sûr mais il ya pire que
mourir dans la vie croupir en prison
c'est purement mourir mais moi j'ai pris
le métro mais
j'entends ça qu'il
sait pas s'il avait dit une fois qu'il
est le meilleur mais la relève est là
comme matinale elle va prendre quatorze
jours de mitard
je pense à tous les autres détenus
surtout épreuve voilà bien la vraie vie
il faut il des tous les os des morceaux
parents de miley ça qu'est ce qui peut
bien son
bourreau qui pense jamais aux victimes
du tout mais je dis juste que voilà il
paye des impôts c'est l'émotion celle
que voilà et quelqu'un s'est récemment
dit ça revient à instaurer la peine de
mort et que l'après peine de mort c'est
profondément inhumain c'est le mind
cayenne des travaux forcés
ce qu'il a commis
oui monsieur non ce qu'il a fait lui
c'est humain sinon puisqu'il a fait
d'elle le landais jeudi ce qui fait
c'est ce qu'il a fait c'est atroce
voyage je dis qu'on aurait donc répondre
il faut quoi ils m'ont répondu à la
barbarie pas vraiment j'ai deux enfants
mais maintenant ils sont ils sont grands
ils peuvent arriver il faut arriver un
malheur quand même c'est ton staff ça ma
fille j'ai pu de vie moi c'est fini le
tour de l'île madame ans je me lève pas
le matin par fr guinée avec mon camion
je cherche le mec mais sept ans et c'est
pour ça que c'est une justice est guéri
que les effectifs du saumon la justice
regard de la justice il fait l an passé
dans l'arceau sur une meuf lama fabien
rambert la prison ils tiennent la main
ferme
comprend ta colère
vraiment c contient mairie tu tu parles
avec tonton coeur et la raison dont il a
raison et je peux l'entendre sauf que la
justice et l'état de droit ne peut pas
juste être drainée par l'émotion ou par
ta colère c'est pas la colère la justice
c'est pas la vengeance la justice c'est
pas l'émotion la justice la justice et
cartésien ces carrés voilà donc là en
l'occurrence il se passe et on ne peut
pas dire c'est tout blanc ou tout noir
et fait
vraiment vraiment guy georges tu sais ya
guy georges on connaît tous la sphère de
guides george hill a pris 20 ans
normalement il ne s'agit vergy lille et
calais normalement il peut faire une
demande pour sortir sarthe il a tué et
il a violé et tué sept femmes et je sais
c'est pas une pas deux chats trois sets
non il peut faire une demande là et dire
je veux sortir et quand les médecins
nous ont dit si tu sors qu'est ce que tu
vas faire vas-y je recommence direct il
peut faire une demande pour sortir grâce
à ces événements alors j'espère que tu
as raison tu ne voudrais pas qu'il aura
bel et bon mais la loi ne dit qu'il peut
faire chauffer 1 voilà il peut sortir
moi ça merci j'ai du mal avec sa
marmaille compenser téléspectateurs oui
oui à 90 % voilà non à 12% envoyé ce
soir c'est très très tranchées 1